[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing albus dumbledore azkaban
and the false imprisonment of sirius
black sirius held from the powerful
wizarding family
the blacks and while many of his family
members were advocates of
blood purity sirius did not share the
same belief
many members of the black family would
follow very dark parts
and sirius was an exception to this
sirius black started at hogwarts in the
year 1971
the same year that peter pettigrew remus
lupin and james potter began attending
the school
the quartet of boys would eventually
form a group called the marauders
and one thing that they all had in
common was they're all gryffindors
before long the boys were graduating
from hogwarts and went on to join the
order of the phoenix
a secret society founded by albus
dumbledore the deposed lord voldemort
the entire purpose of the order was to
oppose voldemort and the death eaters
and they were a vital defense against
their opposition during the first
visiting war
however it turned out that not all
members of the order
were good as sirius's old friend peter
pettigrew would go on to frame sirius
for a heinous crime in 1981 pettigrew
murdered 12
muggles using a dark and powerful
blasting curse
simultaneously destroying hundreds of
feet of sewer system
and leaving a 40-foot crater in the
ground someway
somehow sirius black was blamed and was
promptly sent to azkaban
after being banished to azkaban
seemingly the whole world
turned on sirius even the ghost portrait
of the fat lady
and he was left there to rot for an
astonishing 12 years
he was eventually able to escape the
island fortress by turning into his
animagus form
a black dog and squeezing through the
bars there are a few things that i
always found interesting about sirius's
imprisonment
first of all why didn't he get a proper
trial all of the death eaters did
bellatrix the woman with the heavy
lidded eyes
looked up a crouch and called the dark
lord will rise again
crouch throw us into azkaban we will
wait
he will rise again and will come for us
he will reward us beyond any of his
other supporters
we alone were faithful we alone tried to
find him
and then kakaroth crouch is going to let
him out
moody breathed quietly to dumbledore
he's done a deal with him
took me six months to track him down and
crouch is going to let him go if he's
got enough new names
let's hear this information i say and
throw him straight back to the demanders
and even snape who switched sides
towards the end of the war
and pledge allegiance to dumbledore was
simply acquitted of his crimes on
dumbledore's word
snape has been cleared by this council
said crouch disdainfully
he's been vouched for by albus
dumbledore so my question is this
if dumbledore's word was enough to clear
a former death eater full charges
why couldn't he have freed sirius sirius
was a former member of the order
his own organization why couldn't
anything have been done to help him
was dumbledore convinced of sirius's
innocence or was a veil pulled over his
eyes
just like everyone else if we look at
the text further we can derive some
answers from dumbledore himself
it is your turn to listen and i beg you
will not interrupt me
because there is very little time he
said quietly there is not a shred of
proof
to support black's story except your
word and the word of two
thirteen-year-old wizards will not
convince anybody
a street full of eyewitnesses swore they
saw serious murder pettigrew
i myself gave evidence to the ministry
sirius had been the potter's secret
keeper
professor lupin can tell you harry said
unable to stop himself
professor lupin is currently deep in the
forest unable to tell anyone anything
by the time he is human again it will be
too late sirius will be worse than dead
i might add that werewolves are so
mistrusted by most of our kind
and his support will count for very
little and the fact that he and sirius
are old friends but listen to me harry
it is too late you understand me you
must see the professor snape's version
of events
is far more convincing than yours he
hates sirius
hermione said desperately all because of
some stupid trick sirius played on him
sirius has not acted like an innocent
man the attack on the fat lady
entering gryffindor tower with a knife
without pettigrew
alive or dead we have no chance of
overturning sirius's sentence
but you believe us yes i do said
dumbledore quietly
but i have no power to make other men
see the truth or to overrule the
minister of magic
this tells us a few things first of all
dumbledore was still under the
impression
that sirius black had been secret keeper
for the potters
and if this is the case it makes total
sense that he would believe
that sirius was guilty up until this
point that would have meant that he
would have been the one to reveal the
potter's location
next it looks like severus snape who had
recently changed allegiance
had told dumbledore his own story about
the events of the night
and i would imagine he too was tricked
by the stunt the petty crew pulled off
as at this point he was being completely
honest and transparent
he hated sirius but i don't think that
he would have gone as far as to frame
him
for that sort of crime even when harry
says to dumbledore
but you believe this and he responds yes
i do
there is what seems to be a lack of
authenticity present
every other part of their conversation
still seems to suggest that dumbledore
believes
he is guilty it is not until he is given
unequivocal evidence
and he firmly believes sirius's
innocence pettigrew's framing of sirius
was really quite impressive
it was the perfect crime and i think
that that is why he was even able to
convince the likes of snape
and dumbledore petticrew knew right away
that he would need to be the one to
frame sirius for the betrayal of lily
and james
as sirius was the only other person that
knew about him being secret keeper
everyone else was still under the
impression that it was serious
petticrew baited or allowed himself to
be found
by sirius who was still furious after
discovering what had happened to the
potters
pataku was in a muggle town surrounded
by muggles
which ensured that he wouldn't have had
any proper witnesses nearby for the
crime that he was about to commit
when sirius arrived pettigrew feigned
grief over the loss of the potters
but his tune quickly changed and he
promptly produced a powerful blasting
curse
then before i could curse him he blew
apart the street with the one behind his
back
killed everyone within 20 feet of
himself and sped down into the sewer
with the other rats
besides the marauders only remus lupin
knew that petticrew was an animagus
and so he really would have been
sirius's last hope however
lupin who was unsure of what to think
anymore felt that the evidence against
sirius was too strong
and didn't say a word pettigrew had
cunningly chopped off his own finger
before departing into the sewer
which he left behind as evidence of his
death because he was
dead to the world his innocence was
implicit which ensured that all fingers
pointed at
sirius there he was in a street full of
dead muggles
with his former friend's finger on the
ground in front of him
surely he was guilty because fudge was
the first to appear on scene
sirius was never given a trial or any
possibility of exonerating himself
he recalls the aftermath of that evening
in great detail
a crater in the middle of the street so
deep it had cracked the sewer below
bodies everywhere muggles screaming and
black standing there laughing
with what was left of pettigrew in front
of him a heap of bloodstained robes and
a few
a few fragments and what's most
interesting about what fudge saw
was that sirius was laughing from the
outside he truly came across as a crazed
murderous lunatic that took pleasure in
the heinous crime that he had committed
or in reality he was a man that couldn't
help but laugh
as the world he knew crumbled around him
one of his childhood friends was dead
the other had switched sides he was
surrounded by the bodies of muggles
and now he would have to live knowing
the recommendation that he made to the
potters
to make pettigrew's secret keeper
sirius's story is truly a tragic one
and pettigrew's framing of him was
exceedingly well done convincing even
albus
dumbledore and that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time
your wizard hurry
[Music]
you